[Music]
nice drugs
i like yours too hey everyone my name is
ash carlson and it's time to talk about
the wanda vision finale
and i figured i can't do this alone i
gotta do i gotta pull in one of my
besties here we have
hector navarro from heroes reforged one
of my favorite people
comic book aficionado um and wonderful
person to have this discussion with how
are you hector
i am fantastic ash thank you so much for
having me uh you're also one of my
favorite people
so i'm really excited to get to talk
about some marvel stuff this finale
how did you feel about it overall
thoughts did it meet your expectations
did it exceed them
it overall thoughts i really love this
finale and i love the show
as a whole but the finale especially my
biggest
thing is that i just wanted people to
fall in love with wanda
and vision as a couple i'm a huge fan of
the characters from the comic books and
knowing that they've been up to this
point basically supporting roles good
supporting roles
in the films but the show to me did what
i really hoped it would do which is add
way more character work for wanda for
vision and it made me really care about
them and i was choking up in this finale
there was some moments of real
tenderness and some real
beauty uh so despite all the comic book
easter eggs and references and seed
planting and all that stuff all that
stuff is fun and great and it's fun to
speculate
but i think that the finale did deliver
on at least what the episode before set
up which was this is
wanda and her grief that's what the show
is
so we're gonna give it to you in the
last episode and i think it did that
especially the last episode when i
started crying for i don't know like the
12th time
in the last few episodes i was like i
can't cry over this girl anymore i
cannot watch her go through
anything else like i'm done like she
only needs good karma from now on
no more bad things can happen to wanda
she's my favorite and she kind of became
my favorite around like infinity war end
game time i was like okay she's clearly
the most powerful she's most badass
she's kind of my favorite like
in that regard but not only wanda like
elizabeth olsen's performance this
entire season has just been
the range this woman has the emmys that
she deserves
the tears she has brought from my eyes
i'm not a crier i cried so much over
this woman
i want to bring up talking about crying
there is a very important
comic book historical moment where
pretty soon into the visions
introduction and at one
point the avengers ask him to join the
team
this synthazoid robot and he like
accepts it
and he goes into the next room and then
he sits there and then like one tear
comes out
and it was a big defining moment for
that character because this is supposed
to be a character who cannot
cry like it's a big deal and i think
they kind of recreated that big tear
moment
at the end when vision has the one tear
and wand is holding his face and
i i loved the context for that well i
have a lot of questions about about
vision and all that we'll get to that
let's let's go
all the way to the end and then we'll
backtrack a little bit so
um there's there's a mid-credits scene
and there's a post-credits scene
let's talk about the big credit scene
first cause we have monica rambo monica
they're asking for you in the theater
she goes in the theater and they're like
uh hi i'm a skrull and somebody wants to
meet with you
what did you think of this scene what do
you think like the implications are here
who's she meeting with
well here's what i honestly i thought it
was ben mendelsohn as talos or talos
from the captain marvel film don't know
how to pronounce it either
just now in my brain i thought of an
idea i'm i'm i'm
sent here from a friend of your an old
friend of your mom's
what if it's nick fury because remember
at the end of spider-man far from home
nick fury is up in space somewhere
because the scrolls talos and talos's
wife
they're covering for fury on earth so
what if and we can't forget this either
lest us forget ash
the wand division does take place before
spider-man far from home
because one division is just three weeks
after end game right and spider-man is
like a couple months it's like the
school year started again they're on a
like it's months from end game what if
monica is getting recruited by
fury for some kind of sword slash shield
operation in space
and fury not only was he friends with
with uh maria rambo from the movie
captain marvel but maybe they kept in
touch
maybe that's how sword was formed maybe
you know for the past 30 years or
whatever since 1995
maria has been working at sword so has
monica young monica
and fury has been an ally or a part of
that so i'm thinking it could be fury
and it could lead into something like
the secret invasion show which is going
to bring back nick fury
ben mendelsohn as talos or taylors and
of course we're going to see her in
captain marvel too but i'm thinking
maybe some fury
maria rambo monica rambo story elements
will be touched on
in captain marvel 2. i don't want to
wait till captain marvel does see
monica again i know i know so then
there's also the post-credits scene with
scarlet witch which i almost
missed because it's like in the other
episodes they've kind of they've had a
couple of mid credits scenes and you're
like okay and that's
it and um you know i kind of started
looking at my phone and i looked up and
i was like did it start playing
another show i was like oh no oh man oh
man
don't leave and until you start seeing
the disney plus credits for like
the voices in foreign territories that's
really when the show is over when disney
plus throws those up and you're like
okay that's not what okay
that's not related to the show i just
watched um what did you make of that
post-credit scene what'd you think of it
when when she saw her um
costume i guess in in that uh vision
pun intended that she had with the mind
stone i was like oh man that's really
cool i really want to see what this
looks like and then we get like the
fully formed thing not only that she's
like reading the dark hold and
i'm so scared for her like is she gonna
be bad is she gonna be good
here's the thing here's the good news
the good news is the scarlet witch is a
superhero in the marvel universe
emphasis on hero
and everybody readers everybody has
treated her that way
even more so than a character like
harley quinn who i think has come into
her own as a hero
since her introduction in the comic
books and in the animated series and all
that stuff i think everybody now
considers harley a hero
was a super villain now a hero i'm not a
witch i don't cast spells
no one taught me magic your power
exceeds that of the sorcerer supreme
the dropped hint uh from agatha saying
you're more powerful than the sorcerer
supreme i think that
i think we're going to see that and i
think that wanda in her
in her attempt to save her son's souls
or something which is very similar to
what happens in the comic books
i think she's going to crack some stuff
open i think she might break some stuff
i think we might see a multiverse
in that regard i mean originally with
vision being dead i thought that doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness was
going to
somehow involve wanda in her grief going
and hopping to other
universes to try to find vision alive
and then bring him over but now i don't
think that's
i really do think that she's kind of
made her piece with vision for now
but her sons that's that we heard tommy
we heard billy say help me mom
save me and she's doing that classic
like almost astral projection like
doctor strange did when he was studying
when he was
like that's what she's and now she's
really embracing the witch side of her
storyline
i think it's going to be bad i think
she's going to lose it a little bit but
i believe that jack schaefer
matt shachman the entire team behind
wanovision are really considering the
stuff kevin feige everybody at marvel
studios they're considering this stuff
and elizabeth olsen has said my favorite
thing about wanda in the comics is when
she
loses it and i feel like they've allowed
elizabeth to
to play that and still play it further
in doctor strange too
while still letting her be a hero she's
not the villain of the story but she
is a character who has is just so
traumatized
and i really think that they hit that
balance really really well so we're
seeing her basically next
most likely in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness which is coming
out in
march 2022 so a year from now
barring these release release dates hold
um so yeah i'm just very curious about
what their dynamic is gonna be
between her and dr strange now because
oh yeah
oh yeah she's the strong one we know
all right the number one thing i want to
talk about is evan peters uh fietro
situation okay who turns out to be a guy
named ralph boner i think
that i think his name might be bonner
but because when monica said it she was
like boner
and then fietro under the control of
agatha was like boner like almost on
behalf of agatha was laughing at the
because i feel like if he came to and
was asked again what's your name he'd be
like bonner it's bonner my name is
pronounced bonner but he's trying to be
an actor he had a headshot
it didn't look like a great situation
for him i i don't know
i don't think i liked it because i want
so badly for evan peters to be in the
mcu
as quicksilver as pietro
so to have him be ralph bonner or
whatever who's just like some actor that
exists in the mcu and that's who evan
peters is in the mcu from this point
forward
um i don't know i he's he's too
good to like do that too listen he's
definitely the highlight
of the x-men movies that he was in but
i am really glad that he's not
quicksilver in the mcu only because
first of all these movies
have to try and avoid the comic book
trope of just bringing back dead
characters
you know quicksilver's death is one
that's kind of lasted up to this but
like there's been
fake out character deaths with loki nick
fury you know i mean i think evan peters
did a great job in this series
and i think that it doesn't necessarily
mean we can't see ralph
bonner again in some capacity but i i
and maybe who knows maybe he'll be roped
in again by agatha for some other
shenanigans or whatever but
if if if we're not getting the fox x-men
movies
that kind of makes me happy because as
much as i love moments from those films
and i have such great
memories and experiences watching those
movies and some of that casting is all
time
i don't want to open it back up to like
okay let's bring back hugh jackman he's
done
so many of these actors were able to
kind of finish out their roles and
and at least evan peters got to you know
be invited to be a part of this show
mess with fans effectively because
everybody immediately assumed it was
going to be like oh multiverse the
multiverse
i had a buddy who when that cameo showed
up he was like uh okay i don't like this
because it's going to
acknowledge those x-men movies that he
didn't like meanwhile i had other
friends and family that when they
watched the show
i'm sitting there looking at him like
yeah yeah uh evan peters right and
they're like i don't i don't get this
what's the big deal
and i'm like he played quicksilver in
x-men days of future pass and they're
like
oh i don't remember so it's just it's
something that doesn't take away
from the the narrative of the show which
is he was recast it doesn't look like
what quicksilver looked like before but
i think it was a real
fun thing for fans to speculate about
for a while maybe we'll get
some version of that where fans will ask
the mcu to bring back evan peters
more and we'll get some version of a
character ralph bonner that he can
i don't know that he can be a part of i
don't know so yeah yeah we'll see
i'm like okay with the cherry picking
the best parts of
some of those movies and bringing people
over because say what you will about new
mutants but
anna tiller joy in that movie is
fantastic and i would love to see her
jump over it's also a different
character i don't know it's also not the
first time
that has happened because they brought
back jk simmons to play
the incomparable jay jonah jameson in
spider-man far from home
people then weren't asking is that a
multiverse confirmation that's not what
everybody just knew they're pulling a
judy dench she was so good as em
in the pierce brosnan films they had to
bring her back to be
m in the daniel craig james bond those
are different realities different
universes still the same actor playing
the same role because they're that good
i mean anna taylor joy
is a uh uh international treasure
uh it would be great to but i also think
like the characters who played in new
mutants and the whole idea of the new
mutants i'm like
if i if it were if i were to have it my
way that is a
a group of characters that would be
revisited but like a long time from now
a while
from now because there's such a great
legacy
addition to the x-men mythos but you've
got to have that initial like okay
here's the first
team of x-men characters and they kind
of grow up and then here's the second
class if you will and that's the new
mutants why are you doing this
[Music]
my programming directive is to destroy
the vision
all right so let's talk about this
vision situation in the finale
um because i think i'm having trouble
understanding it first of all so we have
like
the white vision and then like the
imaginary vision i don't know what to
call these people
yeah he said he was conditional so i'm
calling him the conditional vision
but i'm not the true vision only a
conditional vision
conditional vision the white vision and
then he's like
here's all the memories and then the hex
goes away and then we just don't see him
anymore but i'm like
he's there right he's around he just
like f
off somewhere we're gonna see him again
i'd like to think that he flew off
i'd like to think that the white vision
flew off to a snowy mountaintop to
really contemplate his existence
um i think we will see that vision again
and i think that
the the little construct or or
conditional vision that was created
is in a way vision because then you get
into that fun like you know
metaphysical debates of like what's
what's a soul what's
what's a being what's real if you have
all the memories of as a clone the real
all that stuff is fun but i think that
vision was vision because wanda made him
that way and she said you're the piece
of the mind stone are the piece
of the mind stone that lives in me
which is a very interesting you know way
to um
to bring back vision we knew that in
avengers infinity war they were debating
about
how to take the mind stone out and
destroy it so that thanos wouldn't get
it and they're like well maybe if we can
rewire maybe we can leave the best parts
of vision
in there because he's a bunch of
different things he's jarvis he's ultron
he's tony stark
he's bruce banner and he's the mind
stone which is this thing they didn't
understand
and i think wanda also being the mind
stone in a way
was a good explanation for like well i
can bring him back and it's kind of his
soul
and what he doesn't have is a body well
i can create the body because i can
create
matter and manipulate reality and stuff
so what i think will eventually happen
is that
just like vision said we will it stands
to reason we will
say hello again which is really sweet
[Music]
i think that wanda is going to encounter
that white vision again except he won't
have that
directive from hayward and sword to like
destroy vision or destroy wander
whatever
he will just be without a soul and he'll
have the memories
and maybe wanda putting another piece of
the mind stone that she still
has a part of in her will bring him back
to life and
colorize him and then he'll be sort of
normal vision except he'll only have the
met he won't have the memories of the
vision who was in the hex this whole
show
you won't have that so he'll still be
the vision who died at the end of
infinity war
he'll have the memories of being
reprogrammed by sword and being brought
back online to try to kill
you know his love or this new vision but
he won't like know his kids
so therein lies an interesting juicy
potential conflict
so at one point in the show monica's
like i know aerospace engineer who would
be great at this or whatever
um and to my knowledge we do not get
that answer
at all right do we think i mean okay so
the speculation was that
she was talking about richards and we
were gonna get like the reed richards
reveal and like the
kind of intro into the fantastic four
did you think that was gonna happen
oh absolutely i did and i and i don't
think that the as much emphasis as they
put on to that character i don't think
it was an accident i don't think that
that marvel studios a surprise
oh people really cared about that that
was it no i think they know what they're
doing and i think that we could still
see
a character who is that aerospace
engineer and i
and i it could either be susan storm or
reed richards i really
do think that that could still be the
case um
and i think the reveal could be
something like the next time we do see a
fantastic four
wherever whether it's their movie or
something else that it could kind of
flash back to
sword because they're apparently this
sort of mcu equivalent to nasa
like they're the space program somehow
you know they have astronauts they have
all that stuff
so maybe we'll see some desk guy
and it's a reed richards character and
somebody rolls up and they're like
hey richards we just got back that uh
thing you designed and it was all chewed
up by
scarlet witch the hex or whatever now it
turned into like a you know an 80s van
and it the guy could turn up and be like
really oh that's fantastic like
we could still get something like that
to still pay off
the seed planting that they did is it
disappointing that we didn't get it
in this show right now maybe a little
bit yes but i'm saying there's still a
potential that we could get that
payoff somewhere down the line and then
in retrospect it would make this a
little bit more
meaningful and exciting and interesting
i thought and you know this is one of
those things where it's like
anticipation to your detriment i thought
that might have been one of the
post-credits scenes where
it was like i don't know want to go i
didn't know i was like
i thought when monica went into the
theater i was like okay someone wants to
meet here's your aerospace engineering
movies
hey i showed up i just wanted to see how
my thing went oh it didn't work okay
great bye i'm
in the fantastic four i don't know i'm
john krasinski i mean
richards exactly exactly uh to a lesser
extent
jimmy wu goes to west view in the first
place to find a missing person
yeah like someone from witness
protection that they that's still
missing
do we ever figure out who this is i
don't think we do no i don't think so
and i don't know if that dangling plot
thread will be
addressed but maybe it will i would like
it to i'm hoping that we'll see jimmy
woo again
i'm really hoping that we'll see jimmy
woo be a part of a
team called the agents of atlas which
also included like
shang chi and a bunch of great asian and
asian american
characters in the marvel comics world
which would be awesome
including one of them is like the
totally awesome hulk like there's a lot
of potential there but
it would just be great to have jimmy's
story continue and for that to be
you know um resolved in some way i don't
know if if
i was thinking it was maybe the ralph
bonner character but then i was like no
they saw his face but then maybe in
witness protection program they don't
know what their face looks like
that's part of the the thing maybe the
fbi doesn't know i don't know do they
know
well okay then this but this could be um
because what if this is how he's not
actually ralph bonner because that's his
witness protection page
don't go down this path i'm going down
this i want to
so badly i want to go down this path
what if his real name is
peter maximoff yes and he's from a
different
universe and he's trapped here and he
has to go back quantum
yes yes and then we have to take him
over to quantum mania
and jimmy is going to take him back to
san francisco that maybe like deborah
joe rupp's husband was the i don't know
any of the townspeople could have been
the fbi missing persons but i think
the one that would maybe make the most
sense because the the townsperson who
was maybe the most alone seemingly was
the ralph character
but if they did reveal that i feel like
it would be a little bit like
like ah okay but it's like what's the
real connect who care like what's the
real connection you know what i mean
this guy had a head shot i don't think
he's in witness protection
ralph was a struggling actor apparently
um
so i don't know it would be cool to find
out
okay all right
also i guess like i guess he's agatha's
husband because she
doesn't know what's named ralph yeah
exactly
yeah that's really interesting how do
you feel because you know way more about
this than i do how do you feel about
mephisto not being a thing in this show
that everyone's
fine about the entire time let me let me
take you back
a few years um thanos is introduced in
the marvel cinematic universe and
instantly fans are speculating okay cool
they're gonna have to introduce
death when i say death i mean the cosmic
physical
embodiment of the idea of death in the
universe
in the comic books thanos becomes so
obsessed with her
and enamored by her he's infatuated with
her that he tries to
impress her and that's why he tries to
kill half of or all life in the universe
i think marvel studios is really smart
to not adapt that directly
but they gave thanos a different
motivation that still
results in trying to kill or effectively
killing out killing half of the universe
but it wasn't like this weird sort of
it's easily understandable but it's
maybe not the best story point mephisto
is the literal devil but i am okay that
mephisto wasn't a part of this show
also because frankly some of those comic
book decisions that i was
talking about before that maybe a little
might be a little bit controversial
people have talked about how some of
that agency has been taken from wanda
as a character so this show even though
it told us it was agatha all along it
was not
it was wanda and she was the one who
made those decisions
at first subconsciously and then
consciously to do what she was doing she
was grieving that's what the show is
about and for
it to pull back and reveal some big bad
that was like a male character it would
be another case of like
okay all right well so how really how
much agency does the scarlet witch have
how powerful is she how this or that
so i'm okay with that almost in the same
way that like i was really hoping for a
steven strange cumberbatch cameo but
with that hat
would that have maybe stolen some of the
thunder from
the show you know from from the focus of
the show and i'm like maybe maybe it
would have i don't know so
um mephisto awesome in the comics great
story lines
it's okay he wasn't a part of this show
it's okay
i heard it every week and like every
other tweet and
uh yeah well wrapping up here um
do you have any theories for the future
that are on your mind
from the show um about maybe like tommy
and billy or
darcy i'm wondering if how being in the
hex like affected her
yeah because she was only in it once
like does she just go back to being
human normal life i think i think she's
gonna go back to being human normal life
i'd love to see darcy again
i'd love to see kat dennings again i
think she is one of the best things
about those first two thor movies and
i'd love to see
i'd love to see her in thor love and
thunder for bringing back natty ports
for bringing back natalie portman
maddie ports let's bring back you know
catty denz let's bring him back
um but i think that they they sort of
cleverly explained okay
why out of everybody does monica rambo
get powers she was bouncing back and
forth through the hell you know a bunch
of times
where it seems like everybody else in
the town was like in there once they're
in there once
you know darcy punctured through one
time because otherwise
then that poor woman sarah and her
daughter are going to get powers deborah
joe rupp
is going to get like everybody we get
powers if it was just if you go through
the hex one time
real quick the kids i we're kind of led
to believe tommy and billy are like
they're gone um we kind of touched on
this but then in the post credit you s
you can hear the kids are like mommy
help
so do you think we're gonna see them
again do you think the kids like exist
somehow someway somewhere ah yes and yes
and yes and i think that
we're gonna see the twins come back as
wiccan
and speed and those are some fan
favorite comic book characters
um i think they'll come back and
maybe be adopted by other families
that's sort of what happens in the comic
books they're somehow reincarnated and
then adopted
and then maybe because they don't have
their memories of sort of who they are
and or that they're that their mom was
wanda maximoff and then eventually they
learn that that's where they come from
and wanda reunites with them and it's
all great
it's good happy times but they're
they're really great characters and they
have great dynamics with the rest of the
uh teen heroes that are in the young
avengers and i think that we will see
someday in either a young avengers movie
or a disney plus series
do you think we'll get a season two of
wanda vision i know it was like kind of
set to be a one and
series but i feel like this was like i'm
sure they expected it to be successful
but i think they knocked it out of the
park more than they
imagined they would i don't think we
will
but i think that we may see um i mean
people are really gunning for this like
x-files style spin-off with jimmy and
darcy
you know i i think that i think that
those supporting characters are
hopefully gonna get some more
time in the spotlight including even
monica rambo she had such an amazing
debut in this series
i was watching the show with my
girlfriend and i'm a huge marvel guy and
i love monica rambo she's one of my
favorite characters
and this show got made it to a point
where my girlfriend who doesn't
follow the comic books as much as i do
she's like monica's my favorite
character i love her i can't wait to see
more of her and i'm like good news
she's in captain marvel too good news in
the comic books she eventually leads the
avengers
so they got big plans man tiana paris is
amazing and it's been such a great like
i said debut of this character
uh yeah so we're not gonna get a wanda
vision two
it's a it's a it's a one once you do the
trick i think that's it
no season two to one division but
seasons and movies with all the other
characters related
so it's really exciting time i was gonna
say
uh get some rest because we have about
two weeks before
falcon and winter soldier premieres
right
so and then loki after that and then
what if after that and then yeah
it'll just keep going to the end of time
which i'm completely fine with
but in the meantime um can you let
everybody know where they can find your
work
if they want to hear more from hector
you can follow me on the internet on
twitter and instagram at hector is funny
and you can go to youtube.com
heroesreforged to see me and my buddies
talk about all of this stuff and more
including we're putting up our our
straight up reactions to this show we
film ourselves
yet so if you want to see me reacting to
some of the stuff that happened in the
moment
you can go check that out i love that
and i'm at ashcrossin on twitter.com and
here on et online.com and et live
hector thank you so much for for coming
thanks ash this was so much fun